tous les matins d'après le plan nous
mettrons place et où si je vois un super
un bailleur ensuite regroupés ce
personnel d'opel
et échanger avec os va dynamiser cette
équipe
grâce à cette époque là pour savoir ce
qu'on fait des plus compliqués au plus
facile voire ceux qui invoquent tort
comme avec moi sur vous et vous me dites
vous venez quand même mais à la fin de
la journée vous d'être fatigué il
raconté donc effectivement c'est un
constat que j'ai fait
sur moi même en fin de journée mois qui
restent idron télé le soir pour un job
le journal mais aujourd'hui je suis face
à ce journal
oui mais voilà je me suis posé de
questions nous mêmes aussi ma famille et
ce symptôme de cons vite être fatigué je
me suis interrogé mais le constat vous
l'avez vu avec moi je vous le fais vivre
en direct c'est très dur il faut
toujours rester souriant face à cette
épreuve mais à travers cette épreuve
19 g aux vidéos que nous avons pris
conscience de mettre des choses en place
bizarrement nous ce soir on vous en plus
devenue encore fait savoir
une fois ci
plus avantageux plus cher puis touré
pour
besoin d'espoir
les patients donc
mais très cette solidarité
on joue avec mon collègue à la criée des
heures supplémentaires autres
pas le samedi et nous sommes vos raisons